One of the most important things that we need to address in any cryptography implementation
is one of the most important things that we need to address in any cryptography implementation
is avoiding patterns.
I think we've mentioned a few times how patterns is what kills cryptography and every single
example of where cryptography has failed has usually been because of some key management
implementation issue of where patterns are evident and certainly throughout history
we've seen that many times.
So it's important for organizations in how they implement cryptography solutions to avoid
patterns and patterns are really bad and that's what we're going to try and show here
in this section and we'll talk about certain ways to avoid patterns.
Now here's an example.
You probably know the answer to this.
If we're using English as an example, there are certain language statistics that people
know of the English language.
For example, what's the most commonly used letter in the English alphabet and the answer
to that is the letter E. Well, how could that help some crypt analyst figure it out?
For example, what a key is in a cryptography implementation.
Well, if they've got some cypher text in front of them, they could count all of the letters
and the one that appears the most often might be the letter E because that's the most commonly
used letter in the English alphabet.
Let's keep going here.
The most commonly used three letter word in the English alphabet is the word the.
So if you see some cypher text in front of you, for example, and you see a three letter
word that has been encrypted, you might assume is the letter the and you would approach decrypting
that message in that fashion.
What's the most commonly used four letter word in the English alphabet, the word that?
And this is a really important one because the word that always starts and ends with the
same letter.
So if you see some cypher text where it's a four letter word that has been encrypted,
that starts and ends with the same letter, you can assume and be pretty sure that it
is the word that.
So that provides patterns.
This type of activity in trying to find what certain keys are is called frequency analysis.
And that simply means that people know language statistics about the language that, for example,
something has been encrypted in.
And just to reiterate this problem that we have in how patterns should always be avoided
in anything related to cryptography, simple substitution and transposition ciphers do not
hide patterns.
And you'll remember we showed you this example before.
For example, when we encrypt the word gobbins, the word gobbins has two b's in it.
That provides patterns that may be useful to attackers.
And if you use simple substitution and transposition ciphers, the resulting cypher text also provides
patterns that may provide opportunities for attackers to eventually figure out what
the key is.
So in order to defeat frequency analysis, which is all about understanding what certain
statistics and patterns that exist in certain languages are, we have to create our own languages
and alphabets that nobody knows any language statistics about.
Here's a perfect example.
In this case, we are creating four different alphabets that each start with a different letter.
And the idea is if we want to encrypt the word gobbins, when we do it using this with
a key that is down at the bottom, four, three, one, two.
The idea is the first letter we're going to encrypt is the letter G, but because the first
key value is the number four, we use the fourth alphabet.
So if we intersect the G with the fourth alphabet, we come up with the cypher text letter
C.
Now if we do the next one, the next key value is the number three.
That means we use the third alphabet.
The letter we need to encrypt is the letter U. So if we intersect the letter U with the
third alphabet, it comes up with the cypher text letter R.
Now here's where patterns that appeared in the plaintext actually disappear because
we've created alphabets that nobody knows any language statistics about.
So the first B in the plaintext becomes the letter A as cypher text.
Now the next B will not produce the same A, for example.
So we hide the patterns that existed in the plaintext by creating what are called polyalphabetic
cypheres.
In this case, the second B creates a Z as the cypher text letter.
So patterns are actually hidden.
So what you want to remember about polyalphabetic cypheres, the word poly means many.
So you're creating many alphabets that overall are going to defeat any sort of frequency
analysis capabilities that monoalphabetic cypheres do not.
And a perfect example of this, if we keep going here, you're going to see that we're
going to create some very good cypher text that ultimately hides any patterns that may
have existed in the plaintext itself.
Now, a really good example of something that's been used throughout history to be able to
hide patterns is something called the running key cypher.
And we have examples of this being used during that period after the Second World War when
a lot of the countries didn't trust each other because of what happened at the end of
the Second World War.
So what happened in these cases, a lot of countries placed spies in other countries.
But the way that these spies would communicate back with their home country would have been
using what's called the running key cypher.
And the reason it's called running key cypher is because it requires the same book to
exist at both ends.
So let's say I'm the spy that's been placed in the Soviet Union.
And I'm trying to communicate back with the country here in the US, for example.
And so what I do is I take the message that I want to encrypt and I combine it with text
that appears in a specific part of a book.
So you and I would know that we are starting at page number 32, paragraph one, sentence
number one.
Whatever text that is becomes the key that I combine the secret message that I want
to communicate with you.
And so the way that we combine is using the numeric equivalents of each of the letters
using what you see up on your screen there.
So if we are encrypting the word gobbins as well and that text that appears on that page
starts with the quick brown fox and so on.
What I do is I take the first letter of the secret message and I combine it with the first
letter of the text that appears on that page, which in this case is the T. And if you combine
the two, it comes up with that, right?
Obviously the number G is the seventh letter in the alphabet.
The T is the 20th letter in the alphabet.
So if we add the two, 20 plus seven is 27, that's more letters than we have in the English
alphabet.
So we have to subtract 26, which equals one.
So your first cipher text letter is the first letter in the alphabet, which is the A.
And so if you keep going, the idea is you're going to come up with text.
When you receive that secret message at your end, you're going to have to know where
we started in the book.
You're going to take the encrypted message and you're going to subtract the letters that
appear on page 32, paragraph one, seconds number one.
And that'll allow you to retrieve the encrypted message and be able to read it.
The idea is the next time you and I communicate, we use the same book, but we use a different
portion of the book.
The idea is we've got endless possibilities of keys that we can use in order to encrypt
messages.
There's the really important point and that is we never reuse the same key.
And so every single message will have a different key associated with it.
And that's why these sometimes were referred to as code books.
The idea is before I get to the Soviet Union, I would have a code book just like the one
you see on the screen here.
And we would use a specific page and then once one page was used, it would be destroyed.
And then the next time you and I communicated, we would use a different part of that code
book, which ensures security of each message.
Now the problem with using a different key for every single message is what we call key
distribution.
But this, the running key cipher that we just described where we use the same book at
both ends, but a different part of the book for every single message is ensuring that
we have a different key for every single message.
And this in cryptography actually has a specific term associated with it.
It is known as a one time pad.
So a one time pad means that for every single message that you encrypt, the key is changed
and it's never reused.
And in fact, the key is always the exact same length as the message that you're encrypting.
Because of that, the key is never reused and it's always the same length.
It becomes the only unbreakable algorithm that exists where the key is only used one
and never reused.